He said, I quote, "It would be good for me to have a hot cosplay
girl living in the house." Like, literally him using his connections,
the connections he builds up by having an audience to denigrate
and coersse women. That's probably like a self-contained argument
on why he might be too harmful to be platformed. How about you
play with consensual partners instead?
This post will age very poorly, smiley face. It's like, well,
no, man. >> Actually, you lost, man.
>> Hello. [music]
>> Hey, what's up, man?
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> Going good, dude. >> My mic.
That's cool. What did you think of Miss Cape watching your video
on
>> It was cool. I Well, I don't watch uh when people watch
my videos and stuff, I don't watch it cuz I'm
I only watch the end typically to see if they like it or >> cuz
I'm always worried they're going to like hate it. But he seemed
to really like it. He said it was good, so that was cool.
>> Yeah, he thought it was a shot. I mean, it really is.
I
feel like out of the hit pieces I've watched, it just basically
like you you make it clear where he could respond, how he could
respond, and he never responds like that, right? It's even worse
now that we know the outcome of his civil like I guess protective
order hearing.
>> What do you think of um which >> Oh, go ahead.
>> I was just going to say which is great by the way. I
mean I think this was I was always worried um when Pink was in
uh this whole thing with him cuz with legal stuff you just never
know you know I never
have like any idea of where it's going to go or anything. So,
but uh definitely the best possible outcome I think. So,
>> yeah. Well, for her for sure.
>> Um I do wonder
I don't know like I wonder what happened with any criminal thing
if there's still a criminal thing proceeding. I don't know if
you've ever heard anything about that, >> but like I I
would wonder cuz I know she had something going. As far as I
know, there was just there's just right now the like I think
before she had done something, but I don't know
at all. >> I'm guessing it's just like beyond a
>> like beyond a reasonable doubt to prove something like
this. Um beyond like reasonable doubt to prove some of these
same allegations is very very difficult, right? Like this would
be proven based on the the evidentiary standard would be preponderance
of evidence for a civil case, right? And then that's a lot easier.
It's just like, okay, which way do you lean here? Versus, you
know, beyond a reasonable doubt, which is quite difficult to
meet for any any like
involved case. It's like very difficult to meet that standard.
So, I I could see a criminal case not proceeding forward just
based on a prosecutor saying like, I don't see how we would prove
this.
Yeah. I mean, it just kind of depend. I mean, it'll be interesting
to see what exactly Msk hits because he had somebody in the courtroom,
right? So you'll be able to see like what exactly was covered
because I'm sure there's a ton of stuff in there that the public
has no idea about.
>> Did nobody knew about the whiteboard. I had no idea
about the whiteboard, bro. >> Whiteboard is goofy.
>> dude, literally that's what Ben Thor like another guy
I've covered. This abusive guy, abused his family. He l he does
the same thing. He has this whole whiteboard thing where he'll
like sit down with him and then like manipulate him and gaslight
him with the
>> We've heard of we've heard of Ben Thorp. Yeah, dude.
it's it's crazy. Did you watch some of that? And I'm like trying
to figure out what exactly. So I I think we lost some meaning
there. I don't know if Misk needed to let his his boy cook a
little more or something and explain, but I think some of the
stuff he had in the notepad like it almost didn't really make
sense.
So, I'm trying to think
was saying what what I wanted to do um was actually copy the
notepad and correct the grammar. It seems like when they were
talking about it, he was hastily writing it and so some of the
grammar wasn't correct. Um, so I would like to go through and
actually correct some of it.
Like what I'm getting out of this is
that techone was sort of saying like
well eventually you know if we do this and I get comfortable
with you. >> It's the same thing with FM. Yeah. Uh I can't
remember the specific place but I believe that they only had
like two times throughout their something crazy like that. I
think it was single digits. It was not a lot. So it was the same
type of relationship.
>> Oh yeah. I remember the the claim now. Um, but never
mind. Go ahead.
>> Is it a claim you could talk about? I don't even
>> No, I don't think so. I have to keeping track of it
in my head. It's like there's a lot. >> Yeah, I I get it.
Um, okay.
Yeah. So, I'm I'm going I'm going through this and it's like
basically I have these couple things that I'm using to come to
resolutions. is is that the judge said 10 years for the protective
order apparently and it seems like Axian agreed with that that
it's 10 years for a protective order. I know in this district
in Texas, maybe in all of Texas possibly, but for sure in at
least around Austin, 2 years is the normal maximum they have
for protective orders. So if they go from 2 years to 10 years,
that tells me that this testimony did not go well for TechOne.
And so I'm assuming when they're going over this cross that this
cross is really important. And I'm trying to basically take what
they've laid out here, which is not perfect, and then build a
narrative that would make sense where I can go, okay, this is
why they feel like something was proven out. That's like what
I'm trying to put together. >> Axiom said something very
important as far as the 10 years goes. And you might have missed
it cuz it was like really quick cuz Miss Kiff was running the
stream and stuff. But he says literally the judge announces in
while they're at trial that based on everything she believes
that he assaulted Pink that he was like assaulting her. >> And
that and I think probably the the evidence from all that >> leaned
it in a way to where it became so long like a 10year protective
order. That's so crazy. Like it's a long time. So, I think it
has probably a lot to do with that.
>> And like we obviously, you know, we don't have perfect
evidence on this because we well, we'll have to wait for the
transcript for one thing, but even this court, it's not a criminal
trial, right? It's a civil trial, so they're not doing like I
I assume there wasn't a jury there. I assume it's just a judge
ruling on it, right?
>> Um, I don't know for sure.
just the fact that it's a two-year maximum in most cases and
like I looked this up. I used AI. I did. I did. I confess I used
AI. But to go beyond that two-year that normal two-year maximum
is apparently very rare. Okay. And they need a lot of evidence.
And again, I've heard now multiple cases where he was held liable
for the actual assault. They found the judge found that he was
liable for it. So, I don't know. I think
What do you think? I I joke that, you know, we can actually we
don't even have to say allegedly tone anymore. We can just say
tone, you know. >> I don't even know. I mean, I've seen
plenty of people say that. I don't know enough about the law,
but I mean, the judge did say that that she believed, you know,
like on the record or whatever that she believes that he was
like assaulting her. >> Yeah. I'm mostly memeing with the
idea that like this is pretty much what happened with Trump,
right? found liable in a civil suit for insulting somebody and
then people will say, "Oh yeah, he's arrested." And then other
people go, "No, that's defamation."
And you have the same It's like the exact same mapping of concepts
one to one.
>> Legally, canonically tone. Do you think Teone How do
you think Teone is going to respond to this based on your expertise
covering Techone? What do you think the response is going to
be like?
You think he's going to respond tangibly? Do you think he's just
going to like skirt it and and ban people who bring it up and
move on or
>> I really think his only move is to really lean into
the right-wing I mean right-wing God. Um just be like
can he say publicly like that
you've heard a lot of things about me but none of them are true.
Can he just say that? Cuz he'll just say that and then lean into
like the Christianity and the right-wing grift. um
you know say that like these women are out to get him or like
maybe he can vague post about it. I don't know exactly what he
can say but I mean generally speaking I don't think it'll go
over well for him. Even you you even have a chibi reviews or
as I call them reviews saying deleting posts and stuff like that.
So
>> he's a [__] freak. >> He did repost.
Yeah, he did repost and say like, "I fat finger deleted," which
I don't believe, by the way. >> He's lying. He's a [__]
liar. >> Yeah, who who believes that, man. That did not
happen. >> I fat finger deleted, bro. When you go to delete
a post, it literally pops up with a confirmation saying, "Are
you sure you want to do that?"
>> he's a massive
like >> massive massive spur. Like, uh I was talking in
Spicy about this, but he has like this um these trolls from the
Baruto community like Baruto M. Dude, I've seen that
>> and he's like trying to sue them and he's gotten his
uh firearm out on stream to be like you better not you know some
Baruto fans. That's literally it's Buruto fans. >> Wasn't
it so like they were saying like your brother deserves to die
or something and he just lost his mind. What happened to is like
a family member of his and the Buruto people were like you your
your family member deserved this or something. I I remember watching
a video with him and he just lost his [__] mind about
it. You know what I'm talking about? Is this making any sense?
>> Yeah. I forget what the exact reason was, but it's just
funny to me that like the Buruto people are out to get me. They're
like fans of an anime or manga. It's like so ridiculous.
[snorts] It's crazy,
>> But he's a freak. He's He's kind of a weirdo himself
in my opinion.
>> Yeah. One second here.
Ah, fix my headphones real quick. Uh,
Uh yeah, Klein Hila in the chat says, "Thank you for including
the clip of Techone shouting out Dan." I did that on purpose
by
I wanted to get Dan in there cuz I just thought it was funny.
>> Dude, it's uh when you see basically like Dan laying
it out for people, how you just Jesus, the stale stuff.
Let me see here. Um Dan Saltman Teoneaku,
please don't only be minor's videos. Please be other videos.
Here's my video.
Here's another person reacting. Yeah. Hold on. We got talking
with banan Twitch streamers. Here we go. Here we
>> I'm happy that this is here cuz I I do feel like Dan
lays it out for them that like the truth doesn't matter. Just
make sure people are like spreading your narrative. I think he
lays it out in almost no like basically no uncertain terms. We
might have to check this one out too. There's this one in the
Aerodite humanizing episode. Did you check this one out with
Techone and Aerodite? This is a very good
right here. >> Dude, I don't know that much about Not So
Aerodite. Watching that was like insane because it was like someone
trying to have like a counseling session that like on stream.
It's very bizarre to me. The whole thing is just weird as
>> Just like very subtly trying to get him to talk about
when he was touched as a kid, but also trying to be like non-judgmental
and make him feel welcome. And basically when she asked Teone
like where did you feel like really wronged or where did you
what what what have you done that's wrong? Like what are your
biggest mistakes as a content creator? He's like I was too trusting
of people. I actually trust people too much. It's like okay yeah
this guy's crazy. >> I'm too giving
I'm too giving. >> How do you how do you hear somebody
saying [__] like that? You just don't think anything
about it. >> It's pretty wild.
>> It's pretty obvious. The craziest thing about Tech is
um or one of the craziest things is that there was really no
videos uh I didn't see any videos like mine really like going
through the timeline of any of this stuff whatsoever. The only
one I remember was Turkey Tom and he was like kind of defending
him and his he was just kind of laying it out and not
>> Yeah, in my opinion he was. Yeah, I think if you looked
at any of that stuff at all um and actually did your due diligence,
you wouldn't have swept as hard as he did, I guess.
>> Yeah, I think
just like not doing your due diligence,
>> Well, I think there's this thing that depending on how
big, especially if somebody's like rising up >> as a content
creator, which Tech was growing massively over all of last year,
right? like I think he was he was kind of like a he was almost
breaking out of like a midsize creator tier. He was like about
5,000 concurrents and he was like doing pretty well and then
he took a major step forward when he started grifting rightward
and he was growing massively and I think when people see that
there's like this like inhib inhibition that hits commentary
YouTubers where they're like if somebody's growing and I'm going
to do a piece on them I'm going to give them the benefit of the
doubt everywhere.
>> And I think that's what happened to Tom. Dude, I'm so
bad at that stuff. Like >> the doubt a lot.
[laughter] >> My video I'll do I'll attack like right-wing
people and then like left, you know what I mean? I don't give
a [__] I don't It's I don't think about stuff like
that at all. Probably to my >> which is what you find interesting
at like any given time. >> Yeah. Yep. I don't care what
like political side they're on or what they're trying to push
or if they're an ally or some [__] I don't really
care.
>> Did you do a video on Will Stansel?
I I just the stream. >> I love Will Stansel.
>> The stream. Oh, no. I wasn't even talking. You did do
a video on Will Stansel. I thought I was actually talking about
the Minnesota stuff
>> Will Stansel versus um >> I watched a little >> poorly
timed video by the way after they like kind [laughter] of executed
a guy. >> They executed another guy. >> Poorly time.
>> Rough rough rough. >> It was rough. >> Look
at this guy. He looks so goofy with his whistle. And there's
a whole bunch of people whistling at the new video.
>> Oh boy. That's tough. But yeah, Stantel's awesome. I
mean, he was talking about forming his own like revolutionary
cell kind of terrorist cell thing. Oh man, I I would love that.
I'm rooting for it so much for him to like coming together in
real time.
>> Yes. [laughter] >> Yeah.
IRL Stanel Woffen. Let's go. >> They're writing songs executing
people.
>> They're writing what?
They are writing folk people are writing folk songs about Will
Stansel like leading the revolution or whatever like or the fight
against ICE and stuff like they're literally like recording it
and he put it out he posted it but they're actually writing folk
songs about him which is so cool >> dude. Uh I do love
Will Stansel. I do love that whole thing. The most
the most rich man in America some are
>> Yeah. Getting interviewed about how Grog's going to
rape him. But yeah, techone also. I might have to do a third
techone video. I think I probably will, right? Kind of feel like
I should now that it's all like kind of been decided >> wrapped
up and >> and well, I think it's important to just show
that like he refused to respond. He said he had the evidence
that would like uh what would you call it? Absolve him. He said
he had the evidence that would absolve him and then he refused
to talk to you and then you said this is how it is. He said you're
a liar. You're like mentally ill. You hang out with bazookas.
and then he's the one who's found liable for the simple assault.
It's like it just ties it together quite nicely at the end of
the day. >> Yeah.
And I think Misk is gonna provide enough to where I can actually
like have like new stuff and it's like pretty interesting like
Misk's
you know like the last stream he did the stream tonight was good
too but the last one was like peak man like when he announced
all the stuff and like >> started leaking the decision
of the case and everything like that was peak and he's like dancing
and it was awesome >> dude [clears throat] I don't know
about you I think he wasn't going to leak anything about the
court case and I think he just caught a vibe >> I think
the kind of vibe
>> and well he saw your tweet. Yes. Yes. He saw your tweet.
I think he was like he didn't want to do it and then he was like,
"Okay, the story's breaking. I'm going to go for it." And he
he read the vibe perfectly. He went so hard. Oh, it was it was
great when he does his like monologue when he goes to full camera
and he's like, "Tech,
>> I sent one of my ops to your trial and they took notes
on everything,
It was so >> It was so good, man. >> It was so good.
>> I am thinking I want to go back and forth and like kind
of figure out exactly what this transcript means
>> cuz I do think I think basically the way it works is
you degraded Pinky in this way. She didn't like it. And he's
like, "Well, I don't know. Like, she didn't really tell me."
And it's like, "Oh, but hold on. What did What did your ex-wife
not like about what you were doing?" Okay. And I I think there's
some link there where they know that Frame and Pinky had the
same dislike. They express the same dislike and there's basically
two examples and somehow in the cross they catch him. Like I
that's how I feel like this all goes down. That's what my gut
tells me. So I'm very excited for that. You have any other thoughts
on that? Like the transcript and how it might go? You're fixing
the grammar and
>> are you going in the same direction?
>> That's interesting. Would they have access to all the
frame stuff or would I guess they would but Ryan I don't know
like if they signed >> so I'm guessing
that I and obviously I don't know this but in my mind what happened
likely was that Pinky and Frame probably talked at some point
before after the lawsuit and it's like this is off the record
and then they're trying to hint at some of this stuff right so
it would be that they'd have proof but they'd probably have like
hints >> and I'm guessing that Teto might know that he's
not supposed to talk about it But if they catch him just the
right way, maybe he says something. I don't
>> That's again just head cannon me making things up basically,
right? That's just pure speculation. >> Yeah, that I mean
that could be the way it goes. I think uh did do you have his
like notes on Well, he didn't show all of it. He had like these
bullet points of like some of the stuff that they cover
and some of that stuff was interesting like the OTK power thing
like trying to use like oh I can get you this with mythic. >> Oh,
sure.
Let's take a look at this one. Would this be it?
Was this Was it on this one? >> Hold on. I'm >> Oh,
and then being like you can live here for free if you just edit
pictures and thumbnails, but then he like turned it into like
a kind of like a
for uh housing and stuff, right? Her job became >> just
to basically satisfy him.
Yeah, it is pretty crazy
how like I mean if that's how it went
>> here this this is the one we're talking about right
>> oh judge claim he found sufficient evidence to think
he did commit sexual
>> so that's like obviously an important element here right
that the judge basically says in >> given their authority
like hey we we do think you committed this assault and that leads
to the 10ear protective also
>> which is great for Pink as well. >> I mean remember
like >> people don't know but or people probably do know
but they you had like Osman Gold and like all these people defending
Techone basically like co-signing that she was lying or that
you know thing like that she shouldn't be trusted like all his
fans and stuff. So, I'm sure it feels pretty good to have someone
like a judge or something like that be like, you know, we do
believe you. Um, when you're getting
>> Yeah. Especially when you're getting gas from people,
>> Yeah, probably.
>> Yeah. Just like having, you know, when so many people
on the internet believe the person who you feel like abused you.
I'm guessing that's got to be like a total for people like difficult.
have like a massive platform, right? Like she has her um she
had her like only fans and she doesn't do like nudity and stuff.
She just does those little plays or I don't know what you'd call
them. >> But so I mean she had that platform that's not
really the same thing as like a streamer.
>> I feel like that goth girl like oh I in your drink thing
that's probably like slightly more degenerate than actual nudes
in my opinion. But I get it. I get it. It's
I That was [__] crazy. Okay, that was that was wild
stuff.
>> you know, Dude, I bet they're those things probably
do buku numbers, you know, all that stuff. >> They I would
imagine >> probably do. Yeah. No, I'm guessing they go
crazy.
>> but yeah. So, she didn't was saying that she's massive
on Instagram, though. >> Wait, did you hear Msk claim that
she makes like millions of dollars a year off of Instagram and
Only Fans? I'm like, really? And she was like sucking dick over
not paying $1,000 a month or something in rents. Like I that
would be one of the greatest rags to richest stories ever.
>> I think she does. I mean like if you look at her number
>> she's probably making very good money, >> but
it's it's not the like they were doing like she was doing that
to like satisfy techone or whatever, but they were the dating,
you know what I mean? Like it wasn't like a you know what I mean?
They were like a couple, I guess. But um >> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So it wasn't just like for I mean he did that. That's
kind of what he used her for cuz that's all he used her for was
like this [__] machine. But
um
but anyways. Yeah. Uh but I think I think she's probably doing
pretty good if you look at the numbers and stuff. >> Okay.
I
cuz well actually now that you mentioned it, I do think there
was a thing where when she was with Teone, she was like depressed.
And I I don't truly know if it was because of him or what the
I would believe it, but I I have no idea. Right. She was depressed
and then she left him and she was suddenly getting like massive
like she she started working really hard, right? Like she started
putting out way more content and
>> Mhm. What you're saying like what what was your point?
>> Oh, that like basically since she left Teone, she started
making So basically she couldn't pay rent or she was having issues
paying rent maybe at some point or like that's what he claims.
But she once she was away from him, she started making a bunch
more content. She would have maxed out her earning potential
when she's actually posting. >> I don't even know if that's
true. Like if he claims that. I don't even think that's true
to be honest. Like
>> that's probably the arrangement that he did. Like she
was supposed to go in there and he was like, "Oh, you can just
make thumbnails or whatever." But it turned into something else.
But I don't think she like didn't have any money. I don't believe
that. Hey guys, please hit
>> Okay. Uh there's a point here where you see him he posts
like the payment info from Pinky
and I think Misk says this is her paying for bots or him paying
for bots. I don't know if you see some of the payments there
and that's what it
that too.
>> yeah, I'm like interested in that now.
>> Yeah, the bot thing. I talked to a lot of people when
I was making this video and one of the number one things people
brought up was techone botting that they knew he was botting
and da da da but you know nobody was able to give me uh hard
proof so I didn't include it but that was like one of the number
one things like so many people said was like this guy's bot like
crazy.
Um, so I don't even think it comes up in the the videos and stuff
cuz I just didn't have proof like Msk did. But Misg actually
had the the screenshots. So I guess what I'm saying is that like
that was like a known thing and something that came up a lot
uh from a lot of different people.
>> Yeah, it's somewhere where you post like receipts of
payments here. And I think Ms. if implies that like oh that wasn't
she wasn't paying for rent or something like somehow
she was giving him money for bots or he was giving her money
for bots. I'm trying to find
where this is here. I can't find in your first video where it
is where the um >> it should be it should be
>> oh that's during the uh
that's where Chud's in there I think
>> the denim stuff like response to the >> I think
so they're right there. That's it right there. Okay. All right.
So, Ash paid you $2,000. You paid Ash 95.
Booge rent 2,000.
>> Why would Okay.
>> I mean 95 that bots. I don't know.
Could be anything though. That's I think he was just making a
reference. 2600
TYTY
for staying. >> Dude, how crazy >> I do think something.
>> I'll go.
>> I was just going to say how crazy is it that Miskf loaned
this guy $300,000 and he tried to pay it all back on PayPal.
Dude, what the hell is wrong with this >> Oh yeah, dude.
That's insane to not go to like a wire transfer or something.
Like I think it's funny because that's like how a lot of crypto
sites work is like once you get once you want to make a large
enough deposit it's just like dude do a wire transfer like don't
pay the fees or whatever of whatever site you're trying to use.
And it's funny cuz that's like 10 grand in or something. And
for Techto he's like paying back 300 grand. He wants to do it
through PayPal. It's crazy man.
>> It's insane.
The other thing is >> Yeah. And then blaming Miz for it.
Like basically saying Miz is up because he wanted to charge me
more. Dude, what? >> I mean, from 1% interest. >> I'd
have to hear >> I'd have to hear Techone talk about it,
but dude, he like put $300,000 loan to move out to like a huge
content house with OT. I mean, like that's crazy. And like if
he didn't actually if Misk didn't charge like crazy. He said
he didn't charge interest. So, you'd have to see what Techton
said, but like dude, he he's setting you up and you're just like
stabbing him in the back. That's insane. That's such [laughter]
scumbag behavior. It's insane. Yeah, it's it's not like you'd
let him, but then you find out what TechTone was really pissed
about. And I know what he brought up was, oh, Msk like painted
me as a and then we went and looked at it. It's like, yeah, it's
maybe a bad comment from Ms. like the video Teone sends him and
says, could you not do this, man? You're reallying with me, right?
And you look at it, it's like he says, oh, Teone likes, you know,
questionably aged girls or something like that. He says it like
pretty
And it's like, well, one, you do, and
I mean, it's kind of bad, but it's You said please don't, and
then he stopped, so I don't even know where we go after
>> I don't know. >> Like, like I think the $300,000
loan offsets that. It might It wouldn't offset like, you know,
it wouldn't offset if he really believed like Emmy got assaulted
or something. It wouldn't offset that, but it offsets a lot,
man.
So, yeah. I don't know. It's crazy.
I think he said 5,000 [clears throat] fees it was 1.3% interest.
>> Well, so Miss said
Oh, did Miss say maybe if he charged him $5,000, 305,000 he wanted
back. I mean, that's fine. But I can't tell if that 5,000 Sorry.
Yeah, I can't tell if that 5,000 is the fees or if that was what
Miskf charged him. But Msk did say like a 1.3% interest loan,
which still is just insane. Yeah, he was unclear cuz he says
1.3% interest, but if that's due to PayPal, then it's not even
interest. If that's just the fees, then that's not interest.
I think he was unclear today. He seemed clear yesterday that
it was PayPal. Yeah. See, people are even not totally sure in
the chat right now. Dude,
dude, who are these people? What subreddit is this? Who is JTO?
Never heard of him. Destiny Antifan. Really doesn't do much
bro. I
>> I'm sorry. I just like >> You probably have ops
all over the place, man.
>> Well, it's big DG guys.
odd guy. I remember him being very conservative in Sy when I
heard him on Destiny streams a few years ago and vaguely remember
him glazing Fentes, but then not long ago I heard Hassan shout
him out and saw clips where he was trying to get Hassan's attention/
leech from Hassan. So it's hard to get a read on him. What?
What
is LSF 100%? Dude, I'm just like, okay, whatever. I can't believe
Miz would talk to this guy. I can't believe Miz would talk to
this guy. Literally just try not to cover this person on stream
at this point. It's been like weeks like this.
>> Yeah. I don't really know anything that's going on with
that like
the Destiny thing. Like I don't know, dude. All that litigation
and stuff. I have no idea. Um
>> he seems pretty confident. I don't know.
>> Well, yeah, he seems pretty confident. Um Pixie did
a tweet today. I retweeted it cuz I I do think it's like actually
a good point to point out. Pixie literally tweeted something
like um I hope you guys see from the the Pinky Chu thing that
what is it?
Important lesson from the TechTown situation. People buy into
the narratives of those who portray false confidence too easily.
Abusers have every incentive to act confident and denigrate their
victims. It's how they maintain a false image and attempt to
intimidate victims. I think this is like just 100% accurate though,
>> Yeah, I think so. I mean, it's the it's I mean, if you're
going to fight
into the specific
>> it's very similar. Yeah.
>> I mean, yeah, like I I mean >> Yeah.
Um he's got a really good lawyer, isn't uh the lawyer he has
defended uh who are they? Bunch of celebrities though. I know
that last time I looked it up. >> Danny Masterson,
>> I think possibly even Cosby.
>> David got the same lawyer as him actually. Or yeah,
because they they joined uh that law firm joined another law
firm, but I think David hired the same law firm that Destiny
has.
>> Damn,
very expensive. I've heard. Hope David makes a lot of money.
Yeah, dude.
You look at the responses. I'm guessing it's going to be a lot
of DJs. This person,
uh, I want my bandwidth back that was spent on compiling this
tweet. My brain cells hurt. You're not a victim. You're an abuser.
to this tracks. There's how Destiny fans in the comments are
behaving the exact same way as TechTome fans. Very interesting.
See, I'm getting pulled back in. We've already been pulled back
in,
>> People love their streamers, man. They have like armies.
Uh, Teone was the same. In fact, the crazy thing is, um, that
first Tech video got brigaded to like I've never put out a video
that got so brigaded.
Uh, but lots of comments like not happy with me and stuff when
I first made that. But it's interesting now the court case is
over.
>> When your primary like defensive strategy is painting
yourself as a victim while pretending not to be a victim that
like in genders a certain audience where they're like very defensive
of the person who's being victimized, right? You create that
loop of you consistently being victimized by bad people. Like
TeeOne and Destiny have like a lot of overlap in that exact way
where they are consistently the victims of like really horrible
people over it's like all of their biggest content arcs is where
they're victims of the the worst people, right? And then that
that engenders an audience where people are showing up to like
defend the person who's been victimized over and over and over
again.
>> Yeah. You're paying
like the
>> Yeah, exactly.
crazy thing about
>> I'll go.
>> I was just going to say this is just random, but I did
notice that uh Destiny the other day when all the Lucaria stuff
happened, he just tweeted out like a like a spreadsheet of the
stuff everyone censored with like all the stuff unblurred. It's
like these links to like all these like sus sites and stuff or
like the files, but it had like the links in them. I was like,
"What the >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Um,
uh, I I was trying to be as careful as I possibly could with
that stuff. It felt pretty dicey to let any of that stuff go
out, you know.
>> Yeah, for sure. >> Dude, a lot of people are um
>> posting the court case.
Oh, and another thing people keep asking uh about the I I said
this in chat earlier in the stream, but with protective orders
and stuff like the uh resolution or whatever like what happened
with it and my understanding is it's not public unless it is
then violated then it'll come up. I still filed a foyer uh to
see if I could get like you know everything but
uh people are saying like oh it might be up in a few days. It
might not come up, but it regardless, I mean, Technone's going
to have to address it or just never say anything about it. So,
>> yeah, that makes me wonder what's going to happen with
like the transcript. Can they really get a transcript of this
case if that's if that's the case here?
A transcript of this hearing? >> They say transcript.
I think it's just going to be his notes. I think it's going to
be his notes. I don't know. I I emailed the the county to see
like what specifically I I could get, which I probably won't
hear back about until uh Monday, but >> at least. Yeah.
>> Yeah. But I I the transcript. I mean,
>> I would have to look it up. But when when Misk and them
say the transcript, I think it's just he's just talking about
like the notes that the guy took. >> I don't think so.
I'm actually pretty sure that's explicitly not what he's talking
about. Um because he said okay he said the transcript wasn't
fully out there and I do think he's planning to go and apply
and get the transcript through the county.
>> Oh, so you think he's going to file it for you? Yeah,
he he uh he might do that. I don't it might take him a minute
to get it. But >> the way it works in Florida is you pay
like the um what is it? The synographers or whatever. You like
pay them. They're like their own private thing that works in
contract with the with the court, right? and you pay them and
unless it's sealed, you can pay for anything that would be a
public hearing. And I'm guessing that Texas and Florida work
very similar in this way where like if you don't explicitly seal
that and anybody was able to come in there publicly, it's basically
to make it so that you could go to the public hearing, right?
That you could go hear the >> or read the transcript. So,
I think that's what it's supposed to be. I don't know how much
longer that's going to last for, right? It does seem Oh. Oh,
>> Pazooka's victory lap. Let's go. >> I I'll watch
this with you. >> We got a Plazooka's victory lap on Tee.
Oh boy.
All right, we What else do we have here? Teone defends his father.
Lying about Hold on. What do we have? Lying about Genshin creators
over Genchin meta. Tone's history and hypocrisy. Full court documents
from Foya. Tectton threatens to sue me. I'm going to go to the
end and then we can check out this Pazooka's thing cuz you're
here. We
>> can check out a little bit more of this. Did Tech really
threaten to sue you? >> Main the court filings. The rest
of the pages I received were just reiterating the allegations
and the type of damages Pink was pursuing at the time. If for
some reason you'd like to see those, you can let me know, but
there's no new information in them that we didn't already cover.
Recently, Tech brought me up on stream implying he's going to
sue me possibly. He essentially started talking about all the
lawyers he has and then directly after this started talking about
me
>> all all the lawyers he has. Seems like we got some confirmation
of that today as well or yesterday. I guess >> I have a
remote lawyer.
>> Some people Somebody in my chat was arguing um >> dude
somebody was arguing like you don't know that he had five lawyers.
I bet it was like three to two actually. I'm like dude why would
you like there's multiple people who heard about this. It seems
unlikely that they just all made it up independently. You know
what I'm saying? >> Yeah. I mean, Miskf put out that video.
There's four there. So,
I'm sure there's five. Not that much of a
>> I don't know. >> I don't know how you walk with
the guy after losing a case where there's like so many of you.
>> You know what I'm saying? >> I mean, they're getting
paid, you know? I don't know. >> Be rough. It'll be rough.
I would just feel like I failed.
Like, this guy paid a whole bunch of money for his defense and
we just couldn't help him. Although I guess it's it's got to
be largely on
>> Got to be >> ballpark it Jtock. How much money
do you think he spent?
>> Um man, that's really hard to say. I I don't know. I
would guess something along the lines of three to four times
as much as she spent. So she had around 50,000. I'm guessing
he had to have paid two 200 250,
>> Yeah. I'm thinking 280. >> Probably would have
gotten more expensive lawyers. Yeah. And I don't know. Those
people would have shown up the day of, but it would have just
been the law firms representing him while doing like the paperwork
or figuring out how to defend him, right? So, I don't know how
they would have built
>> Well, and he had all the cons I'm sure he had lots of
consultations and explaining everything, right? Cuz this was
just like a trial, so I'm sure they had to like actually like
talk to him and figure all this out.
>> Yeah, sure. Yeah, that makes sense. >> A other
lawyer. And then two days ago, I got another lawyer. So, I have
three lawyers now. Finally, I think I have a LAWYER THAT CAN
ACTUALLY do something that I need, which is great. Which is a
always a good sign when you shop through people at a profession
and you keep having people tell you, "No, we can't do this."
And then you're like, "Oh, I kept I kept looking and finally
there's somebody who can help me." It's like, "Yeah, you probably
found somebody who's ripping you off, buddy. I don't know how
to tell you this." Like, >> yeah, right. You you should
just go to like a mundane lawyer who can tell you how this is
how this usually goes and then just listen to them. Don't don't
tell them like, "No, no, no. My case is special." Bro, they see
all the cases. You don't have any idea.
But I'm I'm guessing you just got
uh What you think? I just don't really know what it
>> Yeah. Um there's this one guy >> there's this
one guy, his name's uh
He made a a quote unquote hit piece. >> That's me. >> It's
weird how he goes back and forth between being able to remember
your name. Starts with an S. It's like sha something and then
he's like there's another guy. His name is Shamu. >> It's
on me. Oh god. My mod linked me this one uh this one video cuz
this guy's been >> Hold on. A prediction on what Chibi,
Nicholas Light, and Nux will say when the official docs are out.
Well, I don't know. Listen, the official docs might not come
out to be honest with you. I have no idea. But
Chibi will keep defending. I have no idea. I don't know much
about Nicholas Light. Kn
I think Nu is the kind of guy who just goes and like doesn't
talk about it. I think Nux just goes silent to be honest with
you. I think Nu avoids things that are inconvenient for the most
part.
>> You have Nicholas Light. Nicholas Dioro.
>> No, Nicholas Light someone else. Nicholas Light
anime YouTuber. Yeah. Yeah. They what they're going to say is
that it wasn't criminal and since it was just civil like you
know there was they might be able to say like it might have been
a female judge or some [__] like that and then they'll
just you know
keep on keep on going I would assume. >> Yeah. True. Nicholas
Yoro is Nicholas heavy not Nicholas Light. So
>> that's obviously. Okay. Uh what is this?
Someone just sent me this for Chiby's like manga tastes. My senpai
is annoying. Some
not womanly looking girl with this guy. Can we agree? This is
an amazing romance
>> Yeah, dude. This he's just all his posts. I follow him
because I want to see him freak out about trolls and stuff and
pull his firearm out, but it's just like it's just constant degenerate.
The guy's like a total freak or whatever.
So, [laughter]
>> dude, I wonder I noticed this person followed me. I
don't know who this person is. I noticed they followed me were
liking a bunch of my tweets and now it looks like they're covering
all of this stuff
up causing >> Oh, cool. >> I'm just curious like
what they're Dude, there's no way this is What is this?
This is like an SCP video. Why is she watching this? What the
Why do Canadians go ballistic in war? Okay, never mind. She's
watching slob. Total slop
Okay, I never mind. I just noticed this person followed me and
I was like, "Oh, maybe this is cool."
It's It might be. I'm not going to look into it right now.
>> Okay, back to what were we going to I wanted to finish
off this >> posting about me on Twitter cuz he thinks it's
going to do something. Doesn't matter, bro. All my advertisers
are Chinese and Japanese and I don't talk to anybody and my channel
relies on me and me alone. The only person who can cancel me
is me. It doesn't matter if I were to kill somebody unless my
account's permanent
me is me. Well, Misk just gave his best effort. Okay,
we'll see. We'll see how it goes. >> Can't do that's the
reality. >> Wow. I have zero interest in any sort of deplatforming
of Techton. I wasn't the one that made any of the allegations.
His ex-wife and ex-girlfriend did. Unlike you, who constantly
whines and complains about why lefty Twitch streamers need to
be banned. I personally want everyone to have a platform and
lessen bans as much as possible. I want more crazy things online,
not less. And the least amount of censorship. >> Let all
of the schizophrenic
go. Let them cook. Okay. More content for the rest of us. Let
them go.
Uh base. All right. Let's uh let's check out this Pazooka's video.
If you guys don't know who Plazookas is, this is the guy who
Teto was mocking in the previous video trying to paint him as
like mentally ill and then hinted that like you could dox this
guy if you wanted to really easily in a super weird way for no
reason. All right, this guy follows tech quite a bit.
Yeah. Oh, no. It was definitely a threat. It was definitely trying
to like brush him off, >> but I think I thought it was
funny cuz Oh, hold on. >> Here's the video. Techone do
not swear. Oh, dude. He already has the He already has his Miz
video out, bro. He's in it. He's actually in it all the way.
Let's go. I didn't realize he was that in it. Met a cafe thing
for the 12 months,
>> but this is the one we want to watch. I think he's basically
not been covering Tech for a while.
>> Bizooka's got to be riding high right now, man. He was
riding high after the uh the videos I made, too. It was awesome.
He was like he was so happy. It was cool, >> dude. It's
funny that he gets like good views on other content, but he will
eventually come back to a logging techone again. Like there was
a while where he was Yeah. doing techie videos all the time.
Like all the time techie videos, by the way, if you do click
into these, there will be at least a couple or there were for
a while. What is this four months ago? I don't know about
>> But Tech would explicitly go and comment on a bunch
of these videos on this one. >> This is the fifth one.
>> Maybe maybe he fell off. >> My name is Pazookas.
This is the >> He used to do it on every single video because
he was using his audience to go after this guy. Like he would
bring him up and then like have his audience go >> comment
and stuff like that. And then eventually one of them doxed him
and all this [__] Uh that's what it sounds like.
But
>> yeah, I I guess it's no more. But yeah, Tone used to
comment on all of this guy's videos. He was like totally he's
crazy about it. All right, so this guy Yeah, this guy follows
a lot of Teone. lot of good reads on Teone to be honest. Like
if you actually go and watch, he's pretty calm in the way he
analyzes him. Like even when Tee's calling this guy crazy. He's
just like he's very a like very aut like very literal, very all
the time, but his reads like aren't bad. He's very calm about
it. He's not like losing his mind. He's not manic. He's not crazy.
Or at least that's the impression I got. I don't know if you
feel like that's pretty fair. >> Maybe a little too little
sometimes. Maybe he doesn't pick up nuance all the
>> He's just like an a log or whatever, right? I that's
what I got from it. I don't I don't think he was out here like
lying or like making anything up, but like he logs all of his
stuff and and whatnot. Um but I like him. I think I mean I think
he's funny. [laughter] >> he was funny. I I did enjoy watching
God >> since that last voyage
I had
with Tech
and the ship has arrived
If you're just joining this channel, my name is Pazookas
and before I started covering Destiny Horizon and then switching
over to video game content,
I covered a person for about one year named Techone.
I did it exclusively as a test to myself. Um, and to
I feel like that's already cope. I I just did it as a test to
myself. I don't know. There's like something deeper than it's
just like I just want to see if I could co I just want to see
if I could watch all of this guy's content all the time. I don't
know about that one. I feel like there's got to be some other
reason. 24-hour
7-day,
you know, mainstream media's
constant appeal to just change topics after topics. You know,
if Trump is a uh tomorrow, he is this or that or that. They always
completely change their topics when in reality,
if you are something and you know you're a second.
>> Yeah. So, I actually talked to Blue Zukas once uh on
a stream like a long time ago. I will say the difference is like
he hates these guys. Like he wants them off. He wants them banned
and like off the platform. I was like and we kind of had an argument
over like I'm not interested in like you know people can have
their platforms or whatever but he like generally does not like
them like he or you know and wants them to be deplatformed and
all this stuff. like he has a like hatred for them for like Techone,
some [clears throat] of the >> OTK. There's like an argument,
right? I think there's a very strong argument when you see when
you see Pinky say use OTK power saying he could get her deals
and with mythic talent. He said, I quote, "It would be good for
me to have a hot cosplay girl living in the house." Like literally
him using his connections, the connections he builds up by having
an audience to denigrate and coers women. That's probably like
a self-contained argument on why he might be too harmful to be
platformed. I don't personally go there, but I don't necessarily
think people are insane for making the argument. Like I think
there is a good argument there. It's just about like the trade-offs
for me.
>> I understand the argument. I'm just way too ingrained
in like, you know, watching like right-wing people be deplatformed
everywhere like in 2020 or whatever year it was. So, it's like
deeply ingrained in me that I just don't want anyone banned.
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I think I like that's where
I lean as well. It's just I I can totally defend the arguments
that get made about it. But yeah, it seems like we're on the
same page there. It's like they're not crazy. It's just no, I
don't I don't like where it ends up basically.
Why don't you just keep covering the thing that is the most important?
And that's the kind of philosophy that I had with TechOne. I
covered the things that were the most important and I kept on
driving them home.
And the only way you can do that is if you have a person that
continues to
allow you.
Because in America, we do have laws that protect against defamation
and other things. But if people continue to dig themselves
into a hole,
well, we also have another constitutional amendment, the second
amendment, where I can or the >> first amendment. Okay.
All right. Sorry. Where I can uh then react and talk about >> this
techn is a real problem and I'm going to exercise my second amendment
right to stop him. No pres [laughter] my thoughts and feelings
about someone's uh thoughts and feelings or their behavior, whatever
else. As far as uh 2026 goes, there's not been any Supreme Court
uh rulings um changing that precedent currently. So, um although
you can be sued for anything and technically I could be sued,
um the chances of the case being successful is limited, which
then leads to today's video. It's been 4 months,
but I've been covering this for, you know, the last uh 3 months.
I knew that Teone had a court case that was pending
and although you do not believe me, no one [clears throat] ever
believes me really. Um, I will have evidence. I will show you
uh the court cases in in in reference and I will also unfortunately
have to show you Misk because he's the only one covering it.
Obviously, he's on a vindication uh tour right now because >> he
he hates all of OTK too. >> Yeah, he all must be destroyed
if you're bazookas. like he's on a mission to destroy everyone
from OTK, which is pretty epic. >> Yeah. [laughter] >> Yeah.
I definitely have problems with Miskf. I definitely have like
problems with the way he's been acting. I do think like he he
has issues with the Emiru stuff that I I think he's getting closer
to realizing like he actually was like, yeah, that that cheese
clip, which isn't even the worst one. He's got the moldy cheese.
I don't know if you know what I'm talking about, but he referenced
it today. He's like, "That was bad. That was like I was like
angry. I came in there. I shouldn't have done that." I'm like,
"Oh, well, there you go. That's like really all you got to say
there." He's got like a lot of behaviors like that where it's
like you have rage issues, you have problems. They're not like
totally, you know, categorically disqualifying you being a a
good person. But
it just seemed like, you know, I the best play for a lot of these
people is to just ignore them, right? To never admit fault because
nobody ever cares. They could just not admit fault for anything.
I thought it was good today. Like, oh, he's like, "Oh, yeah,
that clip was bad." like, oh, that might be growth for him. I
don't know >> because of the Emir
allegations. Um, and let me just do a little side tangent here.
>> People like Asminold,
Licari,
Tekone,
uh, and all the other people that preceded them. There's so many
people, okay, Campbell, whatever his name was. These people should
have never had the platform that they did
because what they do with their platform is abuse it
because inherently they are people that have had traumatic experiences
in their life and unfortunately they haven't had
>> okay caveat here. >> This is all my assumptions.
They haven't had the
I wouldn't say traditional therapy but they haven't dealt with
them accordingly. So when they got fame, they used that fame
in bad ways, including Miskf and all these other people presumably,
you know, obviously uh this is all very assumptions and um I
can't really say for sure, but it does appear to when you see
all these allegations against people um recently,
it does appear to be a pattern and a lot of these people in OTK
uh and potentially in other organizations uh if you look at the
VTuber situation are all troubled people that have had no business
uh becoming as popular as they
And because of the parasocial relationships of content creators,
they've been able to leverage that and literally abuse their
um viewers uh their customers essentially. And that's unfortunate.
It's not, you know, that surprising because this has happened
historically in the past and I've mentioned this previously with
celebrities using their fame to do the very same thing or or
sports stars or anybody else that has notoriety, people in power,
congressmans, senators, presidents and so on and so forth.
you know, uh, philanthropers and and all these other people who
act like they're the great guy to get the notoriety and get their
fame and then they literally um are bad people. Uh, Jeffrey Fogle
or whatever his name is, the subway commercial guy, right? Where
he became super popular and then use that fame to
>> Jared. Yeah. Not Jeffrey >> do a lot of bad a
lot of bad stuff. Okay. Which we won't even get into because
YouTube's demonetization um because who knows why uh they don't
want us talking about this kind of stuff. The the advertisers
the advertisers
uh don't want to talk us don't want us to talk about these kind
of things. But regardless, today's video is going to be on TechOne.
And let me just show you the actual
documentations here. There's a lot to go through, so bear with
me.
Bear with Plazookas. He's a little bit rusty. I want to do this
first.
>> Pazookas is a >> because I want to be fair to
Tech. >> He's got the Nikki De commercial right
>> He's got it. >> You think that I'm this biased?
Uh, you think that I'm, you know, trying to have a vendetta against
>> he's going to he's going to steal my bid. Okay. Wait,
did you guys forget who Pinky She was? Wait, did you guys forget
I I closed all the pictures of her. Never mind.
Hold on. I I find one pretty quick. Hold on. Context.
Yeah. If you guys forgot who Pikachu was, this is Pikachu. Just
if you guys weren't curious who it was, >> I know you'd
forget very easily.
>> I do sometimes have to remind you.
>> No, I wasn't a failed bit. We nailed it. We nailed it.
>> I'm pretty fair and pretty partial.
>> I hate to say it, but I I just stole this from Miskf.
Okay, if you just randomly I don't know if you guys noticed this,
but Miskf just pulls up like the most DGEN like greased up bikini
streamers on on kick >> all the time. He does it all the
time. And I'm like, you know what, that just boosts your your
viewers. Like some people will just see that on the screen. You
get like plus 10 viewers and then two of them sub and you just
build viewership over time.
It's just the it's the obvious strategy. Okay. >> The thing
he brought up the other night. I thought I was going to get in
trouble like watching the M stream and then all of a sudden he
brings up this
>> chick with massive in a bikini like all oiled up just
like gyating. I was like what the [__] But yeah,
I've seen that.
Yeah, it's very funny
um with my coverage and with my opinions. And therefore, I don't
necessarily assume that all
parties are innocent. >> And so, let me start with two
things that I think give Teeon an advantage here. And let me
make sure this narrative is correctly.
>> These are Dude, >> And not hyperbolic. >> He
left this He knew what he was doing this up here. >> This
is a recent 22-hour
um video um which and then and then this comment here is 12 hours.
This would have been after Pingchu won her
um court uh for a protective order against Hectone.
If you know anything about this against Pingchu, it was like
it was like this roleplaying slash um
RP slash and I don't mean role playing, I mean the other thing
uh RP, you know, um BDSM like it was some weird stuff that was
alleged and I do believe there was some playful banter. Whether
or not it approached the level of uh criminal um activity, I
don't know. And let's be very clear, the protective order does
not indicate that.
>> I'll get to that in a minute. >> Reuben Ruben
donated.
>> Innocent until proven, did he?
>> Thank you. Yes, exactly. Reuben Ruby, you get here's
this video which I just found to be. >> So, I didn't get
this from anything before today that there was like a consent
non-consent element here. Was that was that given away by something
that you're aware of before today? Dude, I had I did not know
that they I did not know anything about the whiteboard or the
consent non-consent discussions where he's like, >> you
know, John Maddening why she needs to do this or that. I had
no idea. >> I'm still not certain. As much as I saw like
what Misc was writing down, I'm still not like certain if he
was explaining the differences in like consent or if it was actually
explicitly like CNC stuff they were doing. I'm actually not clear
on that yet. So Pazooka just said it and I think Miscuit was
arguing it.
>> Yeah, my takeaway was that it was um that's what it
was from what what I was reading and like kind of what he explained,
but like I guess I'd have to go back through, but that was my
understanding was that he was kind of yeah, he was like telling
her, "Well, if you don't want to do this non-consensual stuff,
like here's why." And then he would do like a game plan on a
whiteboard is why this should be okay. That was kind of my takeaway.
>> Maybe I really have to see the transcript. I didn't
get it. Maybe we could talk to that guy. Maybe that other guy
is streaming at some point. We could talk to him and see what
he thinks about it because he was writing the notes. Was like
I I can't tell if that was explicitly a consensual non-consensual
or sorry, like a CNC dynamic that they're establishing or if
he was just explaining that like no, you did consent to this
because XYZ
this wasn't non-consensual. It was actually
>> I lean to the CNC thing. Like that's what Misk was clearly
saying, >> but I don't know. I can't tell if that was like
lost in translation or what's going on to be honest.
>> Yeah, some of that stuff was lost in translation. They
should definitely try to like I they'll probably go into it more,
but like the grammar messed them up so it was kind of hard to
understand like exactly what he was saying.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's how that's how I felt >> distasteful
in my opinion. And apparently these guys are working for McDonald's
or for Door Dash or whatever the other delivery services are.
>> For McDonald's.
[laughter] HE'S HE KNOWS THE BIT. HE'S DOING THE BIT.
>> these guys are working for McDonald's and doing this
stuff. That's crazy.
>> Okay. And so I don't know if it was whose idea it was,
but obviously and it's not Pinku that did this. Obviously, Pinkchu
shook shook the hand as in indicating she didn't want any part
of this. But at the same time, like >> associations and
groups and stuff like that can >> This is what I mean by
this guy's like he's like analyzing
>> whether or not she's into CNC based on this like McDonald's
clip. >> Definitely
um identify some behaviors. Uh and Pingchu has no issues with
uh Flaunting herself and to be very provocative. Um >> oh
um
>> okay. Uh
never mind. Press play. I'm sorry. I was having to run >> almost
in a role playing in sense. So there is that aspect that I do
think needs to be mentioned in these cases. Now, I did do >> So,
I need to I need to get his full diagnosis there one more time.
>> And groups and stuff like that can
um identify some behaviors. Uh and Pink Chip has no issues with
uh Flaunting herself and to be very provocative um almost in
a role playing in sense. So, there is that aspect that I do think
needs to be mentioned in these cases. Now, I did do a >> That's
what she does for
>> Well, it is what she does for a living. I do think
maybe you could use this as evidence for like she's she couldn't
say she's never like heard of these dynamics or doesn't like
understand them at all when she's hanging out with people who
like clearly understand it. They're like doing scripts and memeing
about it. Like they probably have some idea. She's she's familiar
with the dynamics. So, depending on what the conversations were,
she probably couldn't say she's like completely non-understanding,
right? Maybe maybe he's just leaning into saying, you know, she
has some understanding and that leans him or leads him to believe
that something
a protective order against Tecton for 10 years. He has about
a 30-day time now and also most likely got to hire a lawyer to
appeal this. I think he can appeal it and I think it would be
successful.
he may not want to because protective orders don't necessarily
go on your record. They can be used against you if like you know
you do have other allegations um in the future. So
I think if he appealed it I'm guessing like an appeal would probably
reduce the time. I don't know if an appeal would necessarily
get it reversed. I I see no reason to believe it would be reversed
based on what's been revealed so far, but I don't know.
>> Yeah, it sounded like it went pretty terribly for TechOne.
Um, so yeah, maybe a reduced time, but I don't know, bro. 10
years is crazy. Like that's a that's a long time. It must have
been pretty
>> Beneficial for someone like Tekone to appeal this to
kind of strike this from any character or any future proceedings.
Um and unfortunately even if someone isn't a violent person or
potentially uh going to commit uh any crimes um you can be you
know alleged you can be accused of it and that might hurt him
in the future as well. So if I were him if he has the money and
the time I would definitely try to appeal this. I'm not saying
he can win because I'm not even sure what the case against
I think he appeals just on the off chance that he could win and
get it reduced and come out and go like oh these guys lied about
me. These people all lied about me. I think that's what he do,
right? Way more than anything else. >> Yeah, I mean, I
can definitely see him doing that for sure. I'm sure he would.
Why not at this point? >> Yeah, that's what it's all about
is just basically try to build a narrative of your own in like
against whatever's being said about you. >> Tim was proceed
in the protective order. And let's get to this.
>> This is the protective order. >> Um, to be fair,
the only thing that has been revealed is some dude's notes, right?
Uh, I mean, there's more than that. I as far as I am aware there's
three different sources of people coming up with very similar
understandings
independent of each other. Now the ground source maybe is you
know Pikachu or some friend of hers that was talking to people.
It could be that they all have the same ground source but I do
think that like at a base level in my opinion it seems very likely
that you know the 10 years no guns um found liable for sex assault.
don't think these elements will change no matter what the overall
story is or what the testimony actually was. I think these things
are to me concrete and I don't see any reason to doubt them.
Certain elements of the stories could be disputed but and we
haven't seen more than just a guy's nose latigious gamer but
I do think it's pretty solid that 10 years for the protective
order no guns and found liable for sexual assault has to pay
lawyer fees. Heard that from a couple different places now.
So, Mike from PA also had somebody in the court. He didn't have
the same source as Msk and had the same overall info. Wait, do
you know that Mike from PA had somebody in the court? Did he
say that somewhere?
Do we have a Mike from PA tweet about this? Hold on. Mike from
Mike from PA. Maybe Hassan does have shooters and they're all
Mike from PA. That's crazy. If he went and had somebody in there,
damn, he's retweeting Pixie as well. Let's go. Uh, okay. Whatever.
I I can't see it. I'm not going to scroll his Twitter all day.
So, >> I don't usually like to talk about someone's first
name. Um, but in this case, it is public record. This is Techone,
John Robertson. Um,
I do think Tech publicized his own name significantly. Like,
I talked to actually Shimu and then a couple other people about
it. I do think Tekone is very clear about what his name is. It's
not something he expects to be to have hidden, right? Like, it's
publicly tied to him on wikis and all kinds of things. Um, the
attorney was uh per year got that's a Texas name right there.
That's a southern name right there. The cause was this. And I've
tried to look up this cause and it's actually difficult to find.
So, I don't have any other uh documentations.
Um, besides
this cause is just the case number. I don't know why he can't
find the cause. That cause is the case number. That's how you
look it up. >> It was at 9:00 a.m. He had to appear. That
was that was part of the uh requirement for the court. Um, so
if you didn't, you would obviously have been found guilty just
off the bat. Um, and maybe even worse, but I doubt it. The court
was uh, uh, court four of the Travis County, I believe. Uh, third
floor protective order. Protective order. And now, if you look
here, I already know that he went, but because other people don't
believe me, we will go and just do the unfortunate. Let's see
if I can find this again. If I go to tech, if I go to misk,
show me, show me the likes. Show me the likes. Bazooka, I want
to see the likes.
And again, I don't really want to use, you know, Msk uh
as any uh reliable source, but in this case, he does provide
at least some evidence
um of this. Uh so, let's let's watch this. I don't know if it'll
be in its entirety. And Techone had a restrainer on him for the
past few months. Technone blocking. Why did Tech just delete
a picture of a gun? You might ask, chat, why did he delete the
picture of the gun? Teone went to court. Teone went to court.
And Techone had a restrainer on him for the past few months.
That's why Te wasn't streaming. Not because he was clearing his
mind. Because Teone wasn't streaming because he had a [__]
restraining order. Okay. This restraining order that Tech had
um it was a few months ago. Okay. He had a court today and in
court Teone was uh tried for assault and um Teone with his five
lawyers.
>> Okay, so here's some caveats. Okay, obviously Miskif
is trying to
bury other people in this OTK
content creation scene because he himself is facing similar allegations.
There was no other lawyers as far as the one posted on the >> I
don't know anything
I don't know anything about Msk's thing. What did she accuse
him of? Like verbal I've heard >> Misk's got some like
>> some like slightly worse stuff >> for me. The
thing with Msk is with the actual thing where he was getting
called like ars insult her. I do think so the allegation there
is him and Emiru were having like fights. They had like kind
of melted down the relationship. He went over to see her at her
place. She was crying. They had an emotional moment. Then they
started making out and then he went to go slide his hand down
her pants and she like yelped. He jumped backwards and then he
said, "I'm sorry." and like left.
that like basically he took an emotionally charged moment where
she was like upset, read it as something which, you know, we
could mock him all day, but it's not impossible that it would
happen. Okay. >> A makeup moment, right? >> Yeah.
Like, who knows what was going through his head. >> Yeah.
Maybe like, oh, we're suddenly
>> I I assume it was like, oh, you know, maybe this could
work. It's emotionally charged. Guys tend to think of like physical
stuff instead of, you know, emotional. She was not in that place.
And he jumps backwards, right? Sorry. She jumps backwards. He
jumps backwards and he leaves.
I think that's misreading signs. I think that's like it's bad,
but it's like,
a ton of people will be guilty of assault if that's just assault
chargeable under the law, right? Like he really didn't keep pushing
forward. At least that's how I interpret it. So, I gave him that
credit. There's other stuff with the Emir stuff that to me is
way worse than that. Not like way worse than the way she presented
it, but I don't trust how she presented it. I I understand how
she feels about it. She probably feels violated, right? Like,
oh, I was really upset and he did this and blah blah blah sees
me as a sexual object. I'm sure there's a whole bunch of emotions
there that don't feel great. But to be to be honest, I just can't
I think that's one of the ones where I I understand maybe how
he miswrote a signal. But there's other stuff like how he was
obsessed with her view account like surpassing his and how when
she would do better, he would like kind of lose his mind. I think
one time he shut the power off at his place. He he like punched
walls. He slammed doors. is he would like throw temper tantrums
when she was like doing better than him or he felt like she was
doing something to with him and I think that's like immature
goofy as right >> but he wasn't like hitting her or
>> the only allegation of physical abuse from what I understand
is the two sides of the story are she said hey don't throw your
phone anymore cuz it might bump into me and like bruise me or
something she's like laying in bed he's about to come to bed
he goes to the shower he throws his phone on the bed right when
he's like going over to the >> and apparently this is something
he'd done a few times. And one of the times the phone bounces
off of the bed after she's asked him not to do it and hits her
in the eye. And she doesn't claim that he threw it at her, but
basically she'd asked him not to do that anymore. It did hit
her in the eye, caused a bruise, and then they had like fights
about that and whether or not that was
that's And if anybody thinks I'm being unfair on either side
there, that's how I read both sides of that. Oh, this is probably
the worst thing is that there's two different women who have
accused Miskf of when he's angry and driving with them that he
will accelerate to like 100 miles an hour. >> Oh, and >> that
one I do. That one is crazy.
>> That one that was >> probably the worst one in
terms of like making somebody scared up until he just >> I
would be terrified.
>> Someone just mentioned it. I actually forgot about that
one though. >> Yeah, driving while you're angry. Like I
I sort of get it. I try not to do that. Like if I'm angry at
somebody and I'm driving, I feel like I explicitly hate the feeling
of feeling out of control in a passenger seat. So I try not to
put other people through. >> That's what I'm saying. Yeah.
I'm a backseat driver like crazy.
>> Like I if if I'm riding with somebody, I
don't like it. Typically I don't like riding in a car with other
people driving. [laughter] Maybe it's cuz I don't like uh not
being in control or something, but I don't know. It's just like
And if they were like accelerating, yeah, that'd be scary, man.
But
>> the other stuff I mean I don't know. You get in fights
and
>> I'd have to hear more about it, I guess. But yeah.
>> No, it is quite bad, but like I don't know when you
get through all of the stuff. There was I think there's some
stuff on her side as well. Like it it sounded like a very toxic
relationship on both sides
and he he easily could have been worse,
>> right? But in terms of the actual sexual assault allegation,
I do think that's probably in terms of her allegations overall.
That felt like actually the weakest part to me shockingly was
the sexual assault one. Like basically all the other conduct
allegations were
Odd. Not usually the case with a lot of these things.
>> Yeah, that didn't sound It's definitely No, no, no,
no. I was just going to say it's definitely not on the level
of uh Tech allegations, I guess. >> No, Tech's alleged
to have done People were calling him a for that for that. Just
that.
>> It's like the most popular female Twitch streamer, right?
>> And with with the most popular like male Twitch streamer
backing up and like amping up those allegations as much as possible.
He didn't do himself any favors because I don't know if you remember
the timeline, but basically Asmin Gold and Emir both came out
and said he was going to spread a story that he threatened her.
He blackmailed her. if you talk about stuff I did, then I'm going
to talk about you rabbits. And they both came out and said that.
And so they kind of cut his legs out cuz he then came out and
talked about the rabbits and it just didn't hit as hard because
they both came out at the same time and basically, you know,
preempted
>> So he didn't do himself any favors when apparently they
they alleged that he was going to blackmail that he was blackmailing
her and then his response was basically like the exact thing
they alleged. Didn't do himself favors there.
Yeah. Okay.
Kind of unlucky. Wait, Emir Asmin was
I don't know what that means. Rap rat, but thank you for the
comment. I appreciate you, buddy. >> That you saw it today.
So, uh, Joffrey, uh, Goodyear, whatever his name is. Um, that
was the lawyer that Tech had present. Um, any other lawyers would
have been maybe some parallegals. Okay, don't listen to any of
this. He was not tried for assault.
Okay, that is slanderous.
Okay, in my opinion, especially coming from someone like Msk
who has quite a platform. But regardless of that, he
I think Msk was misspeaking there. I don't know if he said you
could tell the way Msk was speaking through it that he didn't
really know what he was talking about and I think it has to be
like actual malice in this case, right?
I guess although it's talking about crime, so maybe
>> maybe defamation per se was whatever. Yeah, I don't
think so because he I don't think he meant I think he just didn't
know what the he was talking about there. He just didn't phrase
it correctly. But >> yeah, it would depend on how it tried.
Tried is not even the right word. He was
served a protective order against him saying that you can't be
within a certain or have contact with um the person involved
in the case, which would have been Pinchu, her online personality.
Don't know her real name. Don't really need to know her real
name in my in my opinion. Uh there really isn't any precedent
for that per se. >> Lost Teone
has not a restraining order on from Pake.
He has the upgraded version of a restraining order. >> That's
true. This is This is true. >> Order. Okay. He got an upgraded
restraining order today. Um I forgot what it's called. There's
a name for it.
It is >> a protective order. >> Oh, I didn't notice
that uh Bisk's dad was throwing him aloops the whole time, >> right?
I didn't see Misk's dad was the one who said protective order
there. >> That was funny.
>> I do. People laughed that like he was doing this with
Miskf, but I'm like, man, I'm guessing Msk's like relied on his
parents a lot where he was like depressed and he got kicked out
of his organization and probably fell back to his parents a lot.
I'm guessing his dad is very up to date on everything that's
going on in his life.
order from Pikachu. >> The funniest thing about uh Teone
or uh Miskip's dad being there is that it's kind of like a flex
on um Techone that he can like stream with his non- rapist dad
or whatever. It's pretty funny. There's like almost something
poetic about his dad being there. He like nukes >> It's
very funny. Look at me. I'm going to stream with my non-rapist
dad who loved me growing up. Okay. Never put a gun to my head
once.
>> Put that Put that in your pipe and smoke it. Tech >> Tone
can't own guns. That's why Tech deleted that tweet. He's not
allowed to own any firearm. >> I do believe that this is
an inherent
uh consequence or result of a protective order. You're not allowed
to own guns because you are considered at least generally speaking
violent in some way or another. And that is, you know, definitely
notable. And again, why probably should appeal this if he believes
it is done. Um,
somebody sent me a 2024 Supreme Court ruling where they basically
ruled it was constitutional to take somebody's guns away on a
federal level. Um, if you have any domestic violence civil action
like civil restraining order against you, they take your on a
federal level it becomes illegal for you to own guns, which very
interesting to me. I had no idea about that. And they ruled it
constitutional again in 2024. They upheld that it was totally
legal to do this. Feels kind of shocking. I wouldn't have thought
that. It it feels like, you know, because a single judge can
rule against you on [__] like this. It did feel to
me like that was probably a little too much power, but
surprisingly conservative Supreme Court ruled in favor of it.
>> I don't know >> if if if an injustice has happened
and we'll get to how a protective order is
>> and that might surprise you weapons. Teone is not any
allowed anywhere near >> hundreds of yards. He has to be
away from her. >> That's true. and Teone was was accused
and and the judge agreed of the assault charges that Pink Chu
had. >> All right. And this is the part that I think needs
clarification. This is not a jury.
If Tek was convicted or charged with a assault crime,
he would be allowed to essentially go to a hearing with a jury
of his peers. This is a protective order. This is a different
process in the judicial system. And therefore, a judge is the
only person that you need to grant a protective order. Um, which
some people would probably push back and say it's not it's not
um a good system. But because of past domestic violence occurrences
in this country, there have been cases where people have gotten
restrain orders, which is the easier one to get. You can go to
you can go to a police station, file report, you get a temporary
restrain order and the process and therefore you have some legal
liability if someone comes in your vicinity that is that is under
this uh restraining order. And so it's like a it's a paperwork
trail, right? Um and then the police can respond to that. When
you get a protective order, it's it's a bit more um substantive
because it shows that there could be definitely some retaliation
or some potential u ramifications of your decisions or of your
consequence of your choices and that could result in more violence.
And there have been cases where people only had restraining orders
and unfortunately
um there were people that were uh in worse um or or you know
equally done and then and then and then eventually uh finished
off like these things happen all the time. So these these protective
orders are supposed to be procedural. They're supposed to be
>> for a second >> on the >> Yeah. What's up?
So, just to give everybody an idea of like how bad it would have
to be to have a 10-year protective order, and it's different
states and stuff like that, but just for instance, like um Courtney
Thorp got a protection order against her husband, Ben Thorp,
and uh against with her kids, and he was like smacking her, like
talking about hitting her all the time, was talking about doing
like uh weird like things with like his 13, 14year-old daughter.
And he got like she got like a 2-year restraining order. That's
it. 2-year restraining order.
>> that was it for that.
>> I can't wait to see
I I literally can't wait to see what the transcript stuff is
because I I feel like there just has to be something so ludicrous
in there that he did. Whether it be like maybe one of the videos
was really bad that maybe they found like maybe he had to turn
over videos that he had and maybe one was particularly egregious
or maybe some of their communications were egregious. I feel
like to me it's like he probably made a threat like hey if you
destroy me like this I'm going to come and do something crazy.
I I feel like to me that's where I got to lean >> cuz I
don't know what else rises to the level of like we're giving
you a 10-year protective order right now.
>> Yeah. I would assume that Texas is probably I don't
know. I just assuming I don't know, but I would assume that Texas,
you know, it just seems like it would probably maybe be easier
if it was in a more like liberal state or something, but maybe
that's wrong. But um yeah, it just has to be something really
really bad. Like really bad.
Yeah. Yeah. I just I man I that's why I want to see and maybe
I might go through some of these transcripts to see if I can
like reorder things figure it out or not. Over under on if he
involved playing with loaded gun string set dude no I don't think
that has anything to do with it. I no >> I got no guns
until
>> he wasn't flaing guns until like well after Yeah. He
wasn't flinging guns until well after this Pikachu stuff happened
and
>> he tried to do this gun thing. I don't remember ever
him ever posting guns or talking about guns or anything prior
to the Pink Jew also became really important to him when those
kids in Texas died in the flood and he wanted to go grift and
hang out with the gun youtubers the conservative gun youtubers
>> the Texas gun
>> order but they're not supposed to be so
um slow that they take a jury to um essentially grant and and
that's the process and then obviously ly above that would be
an extra thing. Does this give Pink validity if she goes forward
with a lawsuit or a charge? Possibly.
And again, another reason why Tech should probably appeal this.
>> Yes. Five judges. Techone, five lawyers. Teone had
she had one
and she won. It's again it's very hyperbolic and uh unfortunately
you're dealing with someone that has a bad narrative um syndrome
with misk is not believable but at least there are some aspects
in the and and I'm trying to highlight them of what he's saying
that is correct and I just want to make sure that that is clear
>> that's how bad it was >> his audience does not
like him and this is the I'm going to finish here but his audience
does not like him and here's another little side tangent hello
everybody we're back to this conversation with content creators
all of these communities have these parasocial relationships
with their content creators, their writers, okay? They will do
anything for their content creators. Uh whether it be President
Donald Trump, whether it be Andrew Tate, whether it be Camala
Harris, whether it be uh AOC, whether it be uh Misg, whether
it be XQC, Asangold,
Hassan, all these people have their own echo chamber that exists,
that they have their community that exists, persists, and no
matter what they do, including even Tecton, they will stay with
them because they are mentally,
sometimes physically
traumatized
by these things. This happens in celebrity status as well. If
you become super famous, Timothy Shalamé,
George Clooney, Matt Damon, Ben Affleck, these all have like
orbiters that exist. Uh rock stars, you know, Aerosmith and um
Guns and Roses, [clears throat] they all have groupies and stuff
like that. This is not new. It's just uh been expanded. It's
been evolved to now
essentially have just ordinary regular people which are no better
or worse than a celebrity because celebrities are just as bad
as these people as well. It just allows for more unfortunate
um
uh people to be hurt in my opinion. All right, so here we go.
And I wanted to just highlight this real quick as well. Um apparently
there's some view bot in here going on with uh Tecton. Let's
see if we can play this clip. I have not seen this one just yet.
So let's just watch this. Actually, let's watch. Maybe it's better
if we watch XGC react to this. >> He's getting a nose for
content. I'm a [__] demon. And when you [__]
>> blocking XC's camera though, this is the bot that he
bought, right? [laughter] This is August 24th, right? Another
time he bought bots. >> XD, did you buy my bots with a
cringe ass emoji? Lol. Just say like cuz I do my loot content,
I need my own space. Tech probably have these because I'm a demon
and when you me, I'm going to [__] destroy you.
>> This is the bots that he bought. >> Okay. And
and Okay. So, here's another thing that I haven't talked about,
but there was a viewbot in the scandal that happened and it was
preceded Teone leaving Twitch and and YouTube and all these other
places and it it was like Twitch was cracking out on view bots.
And Teone was accused of doing a lot of these viewbot and specifically
and you might be like, "Well, why would someone want a viewbot
when they already have 2 to 3,000 concurrent viewers?" Teone's
particular field um of expertise,
so to speak, um was gota games. And the more viewers and he was
the highest gotcha content creator at the time >> So defrauding
sponsors defrauding sponsors where is going to go >> he
still is if he comes back um we'll give him a bigger payout for
these uh sponsors. And let me be very clear the sponsors in Gacha
are extremely lucrative. They're insanely lucrative. Obsessive
obsessingly lucrative. Um, we're talking upwards of 100K, but
any given sponsor for a big company can net someone 10K easily.
How >> without even
do you think this is like do you think that there are a lot of
streamers that just that bought and then they get these um advertisement
like deals for like these gotcha people and stuff? Do you think
that that's pretty run-of-the-mill? Like what's your >> Train
seemed to think so. Train seemed to think that it was like tons
of people. I would say
yeah. Yeah. No, I think it's probably insanely prevalent. I think
it's like really prevalent. >> Damn. So, you can just do
that? You can just buy bots and then be like get ad deals for
like just like some [__] that you paid like 30 bucks
for. >> Some of those ad deals Tech was getting like 30
grand, bro.
>> That's what people say, man. Is like >> like you
just buy them. I I personally felt like at some point I do feel
like um FOMO almost cuz I just never looked into it at all. I
was like, "Dude, as soon as I do this, I know, you know how sometimes
I feel like once I'm trying to do it, then everybody's going
to get caught and I'm going to get."
But at some point, I like realized, dude, if I spent the past
year like botting up to and based on what other people bought
to with their viewership, with their like participating audience,
I could have probably gone up to like 14 or 1500 viewers pretty
easily, maybe even 2,000 >> and not gotten banned off the
kick >> and I would have made an insane amount of money.
I would have made insanely more money than I make now, right?
I would have made and I don't know that there would have been
a downside other than like probably once they start dealing with
bots correctly, you see like a massive fall off and you get called
out for it. But I just like if you're making [laughter] if you're
making way more money, they call you out for it. Who cares? You're
making, like I said, Techno is making 30 grand on these
>> uh some of these gotcha advertisements and stuff. They
probably don't give a [__] about that. That's crazy,
man. That's And there's really nothing they can do about it,
right? Like I mean they can kind of see that these if there's
a bunch of new accounts following you, but they can't really
they're always going to be able to find a way around that to
bot. I would assume.
>> Yeah, I assume they'll always be able to bot. Like it's
mostly you look at like chat engagement and stuff, but then some
streamers do stuff where it's like a lot of streamers do stuff
where you can just listen. Like that's the point. Like we're
we're talking right now. There's not really a lot of reason like
I'm not doing a ton of chat engagement. There's not really a
ton of reason that we'd have really high chats right now, right?
So, you want to penalize anybody who's going to do like interview
content where it's like engaged interview content. You kind of
[__] over everybody who's doing stuff like that,
right?
So, I don't know. There's I don't know how you measure it and
get rid of the bots. And
yeah, so I'm talking about the platforms. You're asking about
how the botters like avoid stuff.
I'm just saying platforms mostly check um engagement now. That's
what they're >> But you can bot the engagement, right?
like a you can bot >> you can now that like chat GPT is
in a
>> like good place you can just kind of bot engagement.
Yes. Sometimes I see total nonsense messages and I just ban the
person like if it's like completely if I don't recognize the
name they just followed and it's a total nonsense message that
doesn't track with like anything I've ever said I just ban the
I'm just like I don't know what this is. I always assume like
in Tekton's chat when I would watch it and [clears throat] all
these people were telling me that he botted like these people
that are in that scene or whatever,
they uh I would just always assume I would see like people message
these same the same emojis and like the same message just over
and over and over again. It was really not saying anything. It
was just like the same message over I just always assumed those
were bots. Like it's like I don't even think these are real people
posting. I think it's just bots posting like
You see a lot of like Leo Cex, Kekws, and Patrick Booze in the
big streamers chats on kick for sure.
>> Yeah, you do see a lot of that. >> Not great.
Not the best, man. And all my stupid I recognize all of you.
You guys can't fake your You guys can't fake me out. Okay. I
recognize like all of the >> I've got like 50 to 100 chatters
>> that are here fairly regularly. It's not a big enough
number that I can't just recognize all the names. Okay. You're
not botting. You're all bots. >> They're trying to >> people
spamming emoji. They're bots.
>> I've started now. I'm like trying to get people more
engaged. I'm trying to get people like actually participating
on Twitter and
feel like it helps. >> Twitter's where it's at. If you
want to clip something, listen, if you're watching content and
stuff and you have time, start clipping, man. Start posting and
people will share it and everything. It's fun. I love Twitter,
man. I love >> Clip clip clip. Yeah. Clip clip clip. Always
be clipping. always be >> there's a clip guide. There's
a clip guide in the subreddit, guys.
It's there.
Where is this? The Jaw Clippers Bible. Okay, there's a clipping
guide.
You can go, you can figure out how to clip stuff. Okay, this
explains everything you want for clipping.
Big guide there. All right, go check it out. Back to uh back
to Pazookas.
And the more viewers you have, the more validation you can get
from from these sponsors to pay out big. And he was getting those
big payouts. Um, so anything that he would pay for viewbot in
um and these things come from third third world countries. The
amount of money you have to pay for bot is probably
JTO, do you have a community, a place where people can share
their clips that everyone can go Hold on. You know what we should
do? We should right now live on the stream. Wait, how do I hold
on how do I do it? x.com
communities.
I think it's communities,
Oh, no. Hold on. >> They're pretty OP. I think
I've like never ever
made one. And I should How do I create a community? >> You
should make one >> because
they'll just juice it.
They'll juice it. I see them all the time like in the the Daliban
or there's I think Osman Gold has one. I Miscus has one. I think
it's called Scumbags or something like that. But >> yeah,
yeah, yeah. I should I should get one. Communities. Here we go.
Communities.
Create a community. I want to Can you update these community
names? >> No idea. I haven't made one. Shamu, do you have
an ex community or a Discord?
Um, I used to have a Discord, but a lot of my uh older friends
that have been around for a long time are like massive trolls
and
all that stuff. And so I don't have a Discord anymore because
I don't want to deal [laughter] with
>> I want to watch drama. I want to like participate and
and comment on other people's drama, but I don't want my own
drama. Uh I might make an ex community maybe. I don't know. But
probably not a Discord unless I found someone that like wanted
to run or something, but everyone, you know, everyone else has
a Discord, so it's fine.
>> Yeah. Um I find like it takes a long time to shape a
Discord the way you want it to be. Like my my gen chat, my
I like the people there. It's just worthless for anything content
creation, okay? It's totally worthless, I think. >> And
then you get into where people are
>> attacking you for your Discord and stuff like, "Oh,
well, your Discord did this and oh, his that Discord's crazy."
It's like, that no thank you. >> It's definitely gay. >> What
were you going to say, though?
Oh, I was just going to say I think like
like group chats tend to be better or there's like spicy is the
place where I know a lot of content creators are. If I'm looking
for other content creators who are commenting on stuff, it's
usually spicy. It's like the same group of five to 10 people.
A lot of the time I like want to do something where
>> what did you run from the dorps?
>> No, I was sorry. I thought I thought you were working
on the community thing. Uh, I didn't I just stopped cover I wanted
to cover other stuff. That's all there
>> Oh, I did I did make a community.
>> Israeli Defense Force is what I called it right off
the bat.
>> We'll see.
>> Nice name. Hell yeah, dude. >> Yeah. So, we'll
see. We'll we'll try to figure it out. I'll I'll do more work
on this community like probably after stream. I just didn't want
to I don't even know what the settings are doing. [__]
And so, I'll try to add people and we'll figure it out.
All right.
All right. All right. Yes, the JDF. Okay. Back to your boy
The the communities are good. The coms are good. And yeah, Miz
working on scumbags and stuff. And maybe we get some crossosting
going on there. Some memes going and stuff. I found Shimu from
his Thorps videos. Yeah, I think the first time I ever saw one
of your videos, I thought you were I literally thought cuz you've
got what? Um Oh, Dr. Red Pills. That's who your avatar is, right?
Coach Red Pill. Coach Red. >> Coach Red Pill. Yeah. >> Coach
Red Pill. >> Yeah. And for some reason I just thought you
were like one of the people in those communities. And so I watched
I think like Hormaxer talking to Grace Thorp on a video you did
once and it was disturbing as [__] but I I just thought
you were one of the people who was in the videos. I don't know
why or how.
Do you even know what I'm talking about? Have you done more than
one video on >> [__] Yeah. So yeah. Yeah. I've
done I mean I've done a lot on the Thorps and stuff, but basically
I I definitely wasn't one of the people doing any of that stuff,
but all the stuff from back then was kind of an extension of
like um my group of friends and like the Discord server that
I had at the time. And so we would just kind of like everyone
would look for content everywhere. So those Hormaxer and the
Thorps and all these people were kind of just part of that entire
carnival of stuff that we were like watching and like making
content about and things like that.
>> Okay.
Certainly was. Yeah, it was
>> not great. Okay. It's not great.
>> Lots of crazy.
>> Hey, I'm like a six-year-old man with a 14-year-old
daughter. You know who she should talk to? My buddy Hormaxer
on the internet. That's a great idea. Let's go. probably 100
500 maybe and the amount that you gain from that is thousands
of dollars. So in reality it's a good business move. You you
basically um >> quantifiably increase your profits uh even
with the investment. So it's a great investment in essence but
[clears throat] then again there's just been this backlash about
viewen and here is an example of him view botting miskith um
with in trying to like uh get him caught for acting like he's
a viewer too trying to smear his name as So, this is the kind
of game that's being played on on all sides. And then Miskip
posted this, which is more ironic um considering what Te has
done. Um, and we'll just end this video with that at the end
of this video here. But this is one of his
Destiny's Discord told me you're a weirdo, but you seem pretty
chill. Yeah, Destiny's Discord. Like, listen, I understand that
Destiny's community is going to paint me a certain way. I I obviously
have thoughts about them. I'm mostly trying to just like not
talk about it. You know what I'm saying? person is fairly gross
to me. So, I'm just gonna hang out and do my own thing.
But I I know that they have a lot of hate going >> videos
that he's had uh Check has on his channel, and this is just a
little snippet that he's had about Misk uh specifically, but
it kind of applies to him as well. >> I will say this,
Miz, in case you're watching this. Um I do hope you take care
of yourself. I do. I know you're kind of going down this route
of you want to drop nukes on everybody and watch the whole world
burn. And that's fine and that's dandy. It's not really going
to change anything, is it? Not really. Um,
you can do whatever it is you want to do, but my suggestion is
just that you simply retire, move forward with your life. You
have the money and uh, you know, keep on living. I will say this
in case >> and the same can be applied for techone and
he used this narrative um, to his advantage on his channel. Uh
so much so that he has you know basically not posted really anything
outside of these like little snippets. Um and protect it's extremely
uncommon for him to only post these short amount.
I did I think maybe I should do a post about it but well maybe
it's not even required anymore but people are wondering like
why I was like pretty certain that he as a part of the protective
order like couldn't talk about it. And I went and reviewed like
some of the content and it it seems pretty obvious when you go
and review the actual content he did that like the day after
or the same day as like the protective order getting extended
he comes on and he's like I dude I can't even talk about this
anymore. I guess I'm not even allowed to talk about like he's
clearly referencing that he's being blocked. It's just not 100%
clear if it's by his lawyers or by the actual
>> Yeah. somebody uh I I think he he wasn't a like before
the protective order stuff happened like he was always making
references and titles and talking about her all the time. >> Um
so I don't know if he stopped
>> Yeah. So I don't know if he stopped streaming because
he >> couldn't stop talking about her if the courts asked
him to or if like maybe mythic Talent said, you know, and all
those people said, "Well, just stop streaming and then until
this gets figured out." And then once he lost the suit, I think
Talon was like, "Okay, see you later." But my understanding is
that it was just because he wasn't able to stop talking about
her and like was worried that he would say something that would
get him in trouble.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Amount of videos and I knew and
I just stayed quiet because I wanted to I wanted the legal process
to um continue about the legal proceedings that were happening.
But essentially Oh, >> nice. This guy said he'll stick
around. Let's go. Gambling is bad for you. We have the same message.
I would love to take a gambling deal and just make a whole bunch
of money, but I think it's uh probably not good. >> This
was what he used to he used to do like four to five videos a
day. And then obviously these started doing these. Um and he
talked about everybody
>> also I'll be right back in like 60 seconds, but I can
pause if you want to say something. So just let me know >> about
leaving Austin most likely because the protective order. Um he
probably just Oh, that's probably a reaction to the protective
order fact that he couldn't even be in Austin without violating
the protective order. So he kind of felt like he had to leave
which is a common issue with these protective orders. it kind
of does disadvantage of you um quite greatly and he got ahead
of it so to his credit and then he's like talked about everybody
from Twitch uh you know Rich uh Rich is Rich Campbell Lwig Misk
uh Lassu I don't even know what that one is specifically Pokemon
Nina as you can see I didn't watch all of these um and and I
and I and I was accused of being this uh Techone Orbiter. I've
literally watched very few. This is my main account by the way.
All right, so don't don't get it twisted. I'm not using a different
account. I don't watch many of his videos. I did watch this one.
Um, so like percentage- wise like 5%. Uh, I'm not an orbiter.
I'm not parasocial. I don't have uh what he likes to use, tectone
disorder syndrome. Uh, it's nothing like that. Um, but
disorder syndrome. Are you sure that that's what it is? It's
disord. It's not
Um, very funny. This reminds me of Miskf. I dude I'm not going
to Biskev cuz he was like nice to me today or whatever. But I
will say every single time where he's like I don't watch hater
videos and then you see his history ever and it's got every single
hater video in it and whenever he goes to a hater video it shows
up in his search. He's watched the entire thing and then he consistently
goes through and says,
"Uh, I don't watch hater videos. I don't watch hater videos.
I don't watch hater videos." Wait, why are you guys saying
What did you say, Shimu? >> Nothing. I did. [laughter]
So Ral Kidden House said sl say a slur and then I just went n
and then I muted the mic. I didn't say anything. >> This
video here is ironic. It happened 3 days ago. >> I think
he knew that his court case wasn't going to go well and I wanted
to highlight this particular instance of his clip. >> I
wanted the word I have premium. I'm not editing when I saw
>> where you
>> that's like the one thing I will pay for like happily.
YouTube Premium just not getting ads,
man. It's like it's not even expensive.
>> I do have an ad blocker, but YouTube Premium is like
cheap as and then it works on my phone and my TV.
>> The coolest thing I think about YouTube Premium is that
isn't that the one where it can give you like um a lot of the
stats for like any video that you pick, right? Like on the top
right. That might be like an extension. I don't even know. >> I
think that's an extension. >> That's the only thing I've
seen. >> Yeah. I mean, I don't really care about I mean,
the ads I just use an extension for. So, I've never really thought
about getting premium, but I don't switch very much either. I'm
just like at the
>> Yeah, in my
I'm not saying I'm working out a ton, but in like my home gym,
I've got a TV and I when if I'm watching YouTube on there, it's
nice to not have the ads pop up. I think there's a way you can
do like ad blocking similarly through a TV, but it's just it's
more than I care to figure out, to be honest.
>> Yeah. I just I like YouTube Premium for that. It's nice.
>> You don't have the ability to self-reflect and tell
yourself where you up when potentially you did. I want you to
look over all of your past friendships, all of your past relationships.
Think about >> Dude, that would be a great hook into the
Aerodite video,
right? Did you just hear that? >> I'm not listen.
Or two, you don't have the ability to self-reflect and tell yourself
where you up when potentially you did. I want you to look over.
there's just like no way that Teto could be saying that. >> Um,
you just don't have like the capability to self-reflect at all.
It's like, dude, I I can hear that from a lot of people. I'm
not sure I can hear that from you, man. I'm not sure I can hear
that from you. That's pretty crazy, >> That's pretty nuts.
>> There's so many clips. Imagine all the clips like that.
there are of him talking about like oh every once the lawsuit's
done like I'll be exonerated and there's probably hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds you could grab
>> this one this tweet was fantastic
is a great one okay
um how about you try playing with consensual partners instead
bros mad going back to playing with Cle and Nita how about you
play with consensual partners instead this post will age very
poorly smiley face like Well, no. Well,
>> actually, you lost, man. >> All of your past friendships,
all of your past relationships. Think about all >> I think
this is introspective and reflective of his choices as well,
which let me just say it's an extremely important part of healing
and moving forward with your life and actually becoming a better
person. And that's the promise of America. The problem with someone
like Donald Trump, and not to get on a tangent here, is that
he does not always do the better option. He always does the most
vindictive option. And he's obviously he has people telling him
to do something like that because they are vindictive himself.
And these people,
all people, not just these people, I don't want to isolate them.
They've had trauma, legitimate trauma, um, in their life that
has affected them, that has given them a bitter pill, and they
unfortunately are taken out in the world. Is it the worst taste
ever? Just look at that room. I honestly don't know. I feel like
he bought a furnished place. I feel like he bought a furnished
place or he's he got a something like this. I just I don't know
that he would have gone and bought all of this stuff to be honest
with you.
You're like a 70-year-old conservative woman, a 70-year-old like
Republican retired house like congressperson, state congressperson
to decorate his house. >> Like I don't know. I don't know.
>> Grandpa's office. >> Definitely grandpa coded
>> world if they've given uh the opportunity to do that.
And that's unfortunate. But here's the reality. America has proven
time and time again that our justice system works and that if
given the opportunity to get a second chance, unless it's something
else, unless it's like a disease or a disorder or a mental illness
or whatever else it could be, people try to change and be a better
person. And once that happens, those are the best people in the
world. I'm not giving techone that credit, but this is the start
of that process >> All the people you've ever lost, was
it really them every single time? It's kind of like that red
flag when you talk about that girl and they say, "All of my exes
were toxic."
I don't know about that one.
The odds of that are just so unlikely. And it's either one, you
got ridiculously unlucky, didn't happen,
two, you're a liar, or three, and he's going to say the rword
again. Obviously, the same rhetoric. And this will end my video.
Okay?
And let me set the record. Tecton did not leave because he tried
to get his mind right. Okay? He doesn't have a background like
that because he's this alpha, you know, male Andrew Tate. It's
all an act. Tone is one of the best actors online. I have to
give him credit. He obviously wanted to be a wrestler in his
previous uh uh career. Um and I wish he would have. Uh it would
have been a perfect situation for him. I think he's aging out
of that potential and I just don't think he can unfortunately
get to the point where he needs to. No, he wanted to Tech wanted
to be a wrestler. Yeah, that's true. Uh and he talks about like
there's clips of old clips of Technone talking and he doesn't
sound anything like he does now. Like he def he has this whole
like persona or like the way he talks now that's completely different
than his older clips. And yeah, he wanted to be a wrestler. That's
what he wanted to do before he started streaming. >> Interesting.
I never would have expected it. Oddly >> to become one.
Although I don't really know what WWE looks like today, so maybe
he could. Um, and and there have been obviously transitions from
YouTubers to do that. Uh, Logan and Jake Paul to some, you know,
degree of success or or or not. Um,
so Teone is hopefully on a new arc, but the chances of him being
different when he comes back online, and that is inevitable,
by the way, um, and now that this is done, unless he's going
to go through an appeal process, which could take another 30
days, uh, at some point in time he's going to go on a narrative
arc. um a vindication arc uh most likely or he may not mention
it and just continue to double down on his gotcha or drama farming
or whatever else.
There is a potential that he just ends and he doesn't come back
to any streaming. Maybe he does feel guilty and responsible to
some degree. I'm not saying he does cuz that would you know obviously
potentially um indicate some legal yo
>> how how the is he going to operate in the drama sphere
anymore especially after this man? Like I I don't know how you
operate and do that when you've
>> just call you and that you've lost. >> Does it
change though? >> Protection order. >> I I feel like
in his mind >> he already just was getting called. Do you
think he's even capable of identifying the difference? Cuz I
truly believe he thought everyone just called him a totally unfairly
before. >> That's true. I mean, I guess I I just think
that there him losing the case will hurt him with like some of
the goodwill that he had from people. People will probably look
at a double take. Not everybody. There's always going to be those
guys typically with like underage anime pictures as their profile
that'll probably not going to care, but um I think a lot of people
will. And I don't know it
it's And he can't even talk. He can't even respond to it. They
can say anything they want about him and Pink and all this stuff
and he can't say he can't even say like anything at all. He can't
even respond to it.
Um
I think so he can't respond to it. I do think he'll just block
I do think you can just block a decent amount on Twitter and
be kind of fine, right? People will always bring it up, but
>> for for Teone I don't know how much there'll be like
a concerted effort to consistently go after him unless he's attacking
specific communities, right? Like I'm guessing that Hassan there
will be some contingent of Hassan fans who will always see his
and comment like
But yeah, I don't know. I think I think he could be to I think
>> I was just going to say we'll see how uh strong that
EHD
machine welloiled machine is. If he can just keep attacking Hassan
and like no one gives a [__] [laughter] That's possible.
I think >> that could be the outcome that nothing
>> I do think like those people literally just want Hassan
is bad all the time, >> It's disturbing.
>> Yeah, it's weird. I don't know. I'm not like a big uh
Hassan guy or anything, but it gets to a point where it's like
a little weird,
little too much. But >> both of us are pretty primed to
disagree with Hassan politics a lot and even think maybe maybe
even think he's like a bad person. But it's like dude I he's
not that bad a person. Like like honestly if you want to have
that level of dedication to hatred like Putin, Netanyahu, I feel
like there are some people you could go after who are like cause
a certain amount of destruction in the world where it's like
calibrated a little better. Hassan [__] I don't know,
man. I don't I don't know. I don't see it. Trump. Yeah, Trump.
Sure. Obviously.
Although I don't know about Shimu. I know you're a little like
center right right leaning. >> I'm not a big Trump. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm right wing, but I'm not a I'm not a Zion Dawn fan.
So
Yeah. Yeah.
Asmin. I I think Asmin for most of the lefty people would be
a way better target than Hassan. But they just they got to go
after Hassan, man. They built a temple around taking this guy
out.
And you know, fighting against that orthodoxy is just it's it
is it is literally heresy, man. I don't want to do the does anyone
else think that
like cultish groups are kind of like religion? Culty fan groups
are like religion. I don't want to feel
Plazukas was talking about that earlier with like content creators.
There's a lot I and I I would say that there's a lot into like
group dynamics and stuff like that as far as like these uh sectors
or like content creators or even just like you know attacking
somebody cuz um you'll get that a lot like uh that one guy No
doubt is was it no doubt the guy that argued with Queenman about
>> uh Ethan Klein denims and all this >> the guy
who totally
completely
>> Will and that guy. >> Yeah. in the marketplace
of ideas. But um yeah, they'll come and they'll be so certain
and then uh you know once they hear once you get down to it and
like you actually talk about it like it's it's a weird thing
because typically they're always like um all their ideas are
supported by like this group of people so they're very confident
in it but when it gets down to brass tax it like doesn't really
end up that way.
>> Yeah. It's always rough when you get somebody who's
like in a big, you know, like they're in an ingroup and then
you see them like talking with an out groupoup about their ideas
and you just you just find out that they basically were just
like gelatin held up by the people who were like around them.
There's nothing there. They don't they don't stand on their own
in any way. They got no idea why they think what they think.
You like talk to them for a second, they cannot they cannot give
you their own ideas at all.
>> And just honestly, you deal with that enough it gets
kind of depressing. you talk to people like that like oh my goodness
this is uh >> well you have this whole you have like a
whole albatross after you that whole DGG thing they hate your
gut so I'm sure you see a lot of that kind of inroup type stuff
going on well and you were part of it too so you probably understand
it
>> yeah
I mean I think I was always the kind of person who like from
that that inroup like signals that it's like kind of cringe to
just always agree like I'm I'm more of a contrarian to begin
with. But you're right. Yeah, it was a part of it. And I don't
think I ever hated Hassan. Like I never felt the need to lie
about Hassan unless it was joking to [__] with him.
Right. But then it's me saying like I'm lying about you to with
you. It's like it feels like a different thing. But maybe that's
some kind of autism, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I also feel like people that
>> that attack to on certain they don't they don't actually
realize that they're like lying about it or realize that like
maybe this clip is like out of context or it's not what it's
actually being said blah blah blah blah. They just like see you
know what Dan Salman put out and or ever whoever retweeted it
or quote we tweeted it and then they just run with that and they're
pretty convinced >> without checking anything. >> Yeah.
I'd say with me specifically, I'm not that like Dan doesn't lie
about me. I do think Dan has some issues with the truth, but
I haven't seen Dan lying about me. I mean, I
uh Dan's interesting. Okay. I think Dan is >> Yeah, I don't
agree with him on any of
>> I don't agree with him on any of that stuff, but um
he is fun to talk to. Like when he was in um >> Chuds or
whatever, just like talking to him about all this crazy [__]
that he's doing or whatever, it's entertaining. I'll say that.
I don't know him like too well or anything, but just it was >> Yep,
he'd definitely be entertaining.
Hold on one second.
I go through my whole backlog of Hana's bads here for everybody.
Okay,
12 Hana's bads. Is bad.
I think I did 14 or 15. And I'm done with those. No more of those
now. You'll be getting them the next time I do them. I'm not
going to do the laugh right now either. But I'm not doing more
Hana's bads right now. I see you guys all doing the donations.
You guys need to chill. I'm not clearing the queue again right
now. Back to we're finishing the Plazooka's video real quick.
But maybe
>> I did just all the ones that were in the queue at that
point. >> Their question about the platforms and his rhetoric
and maybe he just wants to do something different. I'm pretty
sure he can have other opportunities. Um, but >> Oh, Plazookas
was just saying that he thinks Teone's definitely coming back.
I do think Tee doesn't get like he he needs the validation from
this. I actually don't think he can leave. I think no matter
how bad his reputation is, he will keep coming back. I don't
I don't think he can escape. I think he's stuck in this career
forever.
>> Yeah, I agree. >> I think he needs that consistent
validation and he'll never get that from like any other real
life pursuit. I think that's what keeps a lot of creators trapped
to be honest with you.
>> The dopamine hits, man. People love those dopamine hits.
I get it. >> Yeah, it goes pretty crazy. >> And again,
I don't know. Um, and again, I'm not trying to cancel anybody.
So, if he does decide [clears throat] to come back to the platform,
and I'm not saying he can't even do this and be successful, hopefully
he changes a little bit of his rhetoric and tries to be a better
I will not say that I will not cover Teone
if he does come back.
I haven't covered Teone for the past 4 months because I let the
legal proceedings continue and I will let the legal proceedings
continue for the next 30 days and see if he appeals. If he comes
back before then and he says some stupid
I might have to respond to that. My name is Fizookas
and after 4 months you got a techone video from me. Let's see
how long the next one takes.
Bye for now. >> How long do you think the next one's going
to take? How long do you think?
>> Uh, a couple days.
>> Spoiler alert. >> I think I got one. >> My
name is Pazooka. >> It's already It's already out. Oh my
>> No, I don't think we're going to do a whole other Pookas
>> video right now, but I do appreciate his commitment.
Okay, Tech, do you swear to tell the whole truth and nothing
but the truth? Yes, Techone lied for years. >> This guy's
awesome, man.
But I think I'm gonna head out, J. It was good talking to you,
man. >> Yeah. Thanks for coming on. Cool having you on.
>> Yeah. Yep. >> Thanks for coming on, man. >> Take
it easy and have a good night. >> Yeah, you too. >> Nope.
What are you going to say? >> Yeah. Have a good night.
>> No, just take it easy. Have a good night. We'll talk
to you later.
>> Bye. Okay.
What are we doing now, guys? Where are we going now? What are
we doing now? What's up now? We did eight hours. We could technically
end the stream possibly. I don't know what I want to do after
this.
What do I have? Oh, wait.
Wait. Stale 2000.
We got stale tent. And I almost